all right Mario yeah
Mario uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally Boyle Heights from
White France
tell me about your family growing up
um I got two sisters and uh two other
brothers and growing up um
you know it's just
boring to um the streets I was always in
the street can I see the movie cane
sorry I can see your face there you go
yeah
basically always in the street growing
up in the street with you know older
homies and
um you know looking out for my sisters
because you know the you know keep them
away from Knuckleheads you know the
gangs are gangs are thick there yeah
yeah and it was it to um one of my
nephews ended up getting shot and then
um
random going to prison and I ended up
doing almost 19 years for murder for
murder yeah yeah
two of my brothers went with me you know
yeah all three of us got busted for the
same murder yeah yeah
and uh when we got out we had the same
problem
you know so um it was a tool
it finally ended that little war thing
ended you know with that other
neighborhood and um we had a meeting and
you know
actually the dudes from the
from the Emma Mexican Mafia
they're the ones that um
squashed all that [__] for us you know
they went over and they talked to him
and uh we had a meeting and that was it
you know everything gets resolved yeah
but how long did it kind of go on
um
for about 20 20 22 years yeah
you know I got out and we were still
gutting them down you know it was it was
bad it was hectic you know
I couldn't go to the store without
carrying a gun on me
you know and it's not till now I don't
have to carry nothing on me what I carry
is a cane
you know
how old are you now
I'm uh 59 59. do you regret getting
involved in all that stuff
yeah yeah but um there was
I I don't see there was any way out of
it you know that's low income you know
moms you know we're living with Mom and
you know
you know it it aged her you know it aged
her to where you know
she's gone now you know and
I miss her you know it's not the same
you know
but um my brothers are still there and
they're they're all right you know we
grew up I guess you know it made us a
little closer
you know as a young man you didn't see
any other option it was just like
as in what just in terms of like staying
away from gangs trying to go to school
no no I was I was too involved in that
you know I always had homeboys at the
house and you know it starts early right
yeah yeah you know and youngsters that
were coming up I I you know I try not to
uh
put [__] into their heads you know to go
and do you know
weigh out [__] the way I did
you know I try to
talk and talk to him you know all hands
into getting some kind of education you
know going and going a different route
than what I did
you know because
I mean if I could do it all over yeah I
I think um
I would you know I would have won this
you know school and all that [__] you
know
yeah the gangs are still going on today
too oh bad bad my neighborhood's still
right there it's not going nowhere it's
been around for years for years you know
what do you think it's really all about
now it's the community I mean you know
the homies they all live right there in
the neighborhood and um
We're Going Barbecue and you know you
ain't got no nobody to come in and drive
by you know doing none of that crazy
[__] no more you know you could actually
have a little barbecue and you know have
listening music and nobody's gonna come
and [__] with you you know
yeah
now more it's more family oriented you
know the neighborhood you know people
are at you know we've all lost somebody
you know
and I just said they brought the
neighborhood a lot closer and then
making that peace treaty I helped it a
lot too you know
yeah
but the gang still exists oh yeah yeah
and it'll be there forever I mean it
ain't going anywhere
you got younger Generations coming out
of Roosevelt I mean
a lot of kids getting into gangs you
know and half of them go into they get
into my neighborhood
you know white fence is a big
neighborhood you know
yeah
do you have children do I I have a I
have a daughter one daughter
yeah
she
came before you were in prison or after
she came when I was in prison I get them
consequent visits oh I see yeah yeah
actually I had her when she was well
when I was in prison you know her mom
came visit me and you know
knocked her up and she had my little
girl
yeah
she's 28 29 now yeah
what's your relationship like with her
it's close yeah real close yeah that's
good yeah
yeah or drugs or alcohol been a part of
your life
um yeah I'm still um messing around with
a little bit of methamphetamine that's
about it
yeah
but um I do it once in a while I don't
do it every day you know
what what do you what does it do for you
what do you do it just wake me up
you know help me walk and [__] you know
Pips Pips Pips my uh
I don't feel the pain as much
you know tired of taking a medication
that knocks me out all day and [__] what
happened to your leg s
um
I got shot and the bullet is still in my
ankle and that [__] you know what it
like they say it's gonna pop up by
itself but the [__] isn't going anywhere
it's still in there
and and that that's what hurts my you
know when I step on it that's what hurts
my my leg
it's a 45 slug it's a big one
you know and uh
I guess I'll be all right
I see dudes
with one leg and you know in the
building I live there's they must dudes
with no legs and they're still getting
around you know and I I that motivates
me a little a little more you know keep
out of a wheelchair yeah
you know seeing all these guys in
wheelchairs around you I said damn
they're still doing it [__] get your ass
up and go you know what's your biggest
fear now at this point in your life
um it isn't dying
um
being alone
you know being alone
I find myself you know secluded all the
time you know and
that's not good it's not good I I got
plenty of that in prison
you know and that feeling I get that
same feeling when I was in prison
I get it when I'm out here and that's
something's wrong there
you know it shouldn't be like that you
spend so much time in prison does that
you know change you in any way yeah yeah
in what way
not really trusting people
you know I've seen a lot of crazy [__]
in there you know over the smallest
thing you know dude getting stabbed in
the back for something real stupid you
know I'm like [__] I imagine it's got to
be hard to be existing with all these
guys that are mentally ill or just
criminally insane yeah and that's your
whole environment yeah and that it
doesn't change it's like that every day
you know
a slave they got to slam down the way
they do like a bunch of animals you know
23 hours out of the [__] day and then
they let you out one one hour into a
little
room no bigger than this
you know you get institutionalized right
yeah yeah
I I I don't like using that word but
it sounds sounds you know just
institutionalizes
you know just that word you know but
yeah that's that's how I'm living my
life you know like but I'm still busted
and [__]
you know
and I better
I carry myself with respect and and you
know I try to
talk to people that you know in a normal
type of way you know and
I really didn't want to even do this
kind of interview you know I just don't
do you know stuff like this you know I'm
like but the guy Doug he was he's been
telling me and you I've seen you out
here a few times you know
but yeah
nervous you know just standing around
here
it can't hurt to share your story with
some young young man who's yeah kind of
going down your path yeah just let them
know what's coming yeah is that what you
do you show it to youngsters I put on
YouTube and people okay people will see
it all right
yeah
YouTube likes to block it from the uh
under 18 crowd but it's the under 18
crowd that needs to see this most yeah
yeah because I mean you joined the gang
what age I was like 10 years old
nine ten years old when you know I
started running around with
you know the little crowd right there
they're not allowed to watch this stuff
yeah yeah
and that's that's bad you know
that's not good finding out the hard way
you know it's not good emotionally what
is what is this life done to you
nothing heartache
a lot of Heartache a lot of hurt
you know a lot of hurt a lot of Sorrow
your dad was in your life or no
he was
but he was a gang member of the stem
cell you know he's from 38th Street
you know yeah
he was there he was there
but that was your role model another
gang member
yeah
old old knucklehead you know
yeah Mario what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
losing my mom
who did that teach you
how um
she gave our our family structure
you know and
I wish you know my daughter is going to
be this you know to pick up and be like
her you know because she she regardless
how how how much time and uh
things we did she never looked at us any
different
you know
she always looked at us the same way you
know she didn't
I never heard anything come out of her
mouth but you know you you just uh no
good you know
gang banging hulum you know none of that
she loved you yeah yeah
unconditionally you know yeah yeah
that she did
yeah
you still have your parents
I got my dad yeah
yeah my mom died a couple years ago yeah
yeah it seems it seems very often the
mom yeah the moms in these communities
are the ones that are really holding the
families together yeah yeah dads are off
doing their yeah Shenanigans yeah
my dad died first and then my mom
yeah
you know one of my brothers got killed
right here on Whittier Boulevard
yeah
after that um things like they um
started getting better
you know
eventually you learned some hard lessons
yeah
it was not even lessons they're just um
but
tragedies you know I would say
that could have been prevented
you know easily yeah I tried talking him
you know my brother hey leave that [__]
alone now man and he won't listen
and uh
they got them they got them you know
you know but I could honestly save and
then dudes that did that there
they're the same way you know
they went with them
you know
yeah
all right Mario thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah no problem no
problem wish you lots of luck from here
now